Google cloud next 2017 hosted a large
number of talks detailing the future of
cloud if you didn't get a chance to
catch the session managing container
engine clusters across multiple teams
then stay tuned because here's the recap
[Music]
as development teams embark into
kubernetes they will inevitably mean to
revisit their project cluster and
namespace organization as new teams need
access or as they prepare for production
into multiple environments this brings
up the ever common question of how do i
configure my environment in practice we
see three typical configurations first
is a shared project shared cluster and
different namespace or namespaces mapped
to different teams the benefit of this
is that it gives you potential cost
savings in proper isolation but now
resource isolation is limited to CPU and
memory a second is one project different
kosta different namespace setup which
gives you improved resource isolation
but you might lose management benefits
third is different project different
cluster and different namespace which
offers greater isolation and billing
control but again lost management
benefits but after a lot of discussions
one of the most powerful setups has to
be doing a different project for
production separating dev test and
production along with shared clusters
and different namespaces for each team
now once you have things isolated the
way you like you can optimize for
resources offered to them to optimize
your quality of service by specifying
CPU and memory limits on your containers
the scheduler can give you a different
quality of service based on resource
requests for your pot either best-effort
burstable or guaranteed of course you
now run into the problem about what the
resource request should be set to
without a strong history of data there's
a big chance you're going to get these
numbers wrong for awhile to help with
that kubernetes has a feature called
initial resources which looks at the
history of resource usage for a
container and sets the requests
automatically based on that history so
that once you've run a container you
don't need to specify the request again
in the future
the system essentially learns what the
right resource request is by observing
it across multiple runs for more
information about how to properly set up
your kubernetes
including some demos and other insights
check out the full talk on YouTube if
you're looking for more recaps on other
great next content make sure to check
out the rest of our playlist and don't
forget the next world tour
coming soon to a city near you
[Music]